this is how the studio breaks you're
watching this video it means I've died
today
it's cliffhanger if you fell off the
cliff and I'm caught you did I get hold
you die we both die
well we're gonna test that theory today
and see just how difficult it is to hang
well someone else holds you off the side
of a cliff so there's something off that
cliff and they reach out and grab them I
know that oh [ __ ] is possible but the
actual holding I think is possible you
think being able to reach down and grab
someone following that fast I don't know
that's possible is the challenge to pull
them up or just hold them hold yeah I
can hold myself to hold them until the
rescue helicopter comes you have to hold
them for long enough to say I'll tell
your wife you love her and then you come
I don't go so we can test this here
because we have a perfectly positioned
ledge and a bunch of willing dudes
strong young boys here to see if you can
hold somebody up with one arm it's not
you that don't just allocate your fuel
to red so you through a green screen in
here because we want to use some really
great amazing high-end visual effects to
show you guys what it's like to be on
the edge of a cliff I'm climbing with my
buddy Nico and then he slips
[Music]
try keep your wrist bent yep don't kill
this Henry go are you watching
[Music]
Jake we're true grit that's how we're
gonna do this the whole lot this is
enough that actions been actually not
working out so well I feel like we need
them this I guess yeah that doesn't
sound very calm maybe like all this goes
like ribcage collapsing under the weight
dude I'm not that what's what's the best
what need you to just grab yeah I'll do
that
two hands on the marriage just like this
man you've Colby's right
cold hands are the creepiest
well I got the message across
I think that was the longest time we had
so far with 16
[Applause]
20 seconds 53 yeah we're getting better
as you know we went to nab last year Ted
from aperture invited us so we're gonna
be going again this year again invited
by aperture of huge thanks to them if
you guys are gonna be there we're gonna
be doing two talks and we'll be tweeting
out those exactly when those are did you
put that there
that's kind of sketchy this is super
weird hey did you guys leave a VHS tape
outside the door no we have a VCR I
think we can play it we have them in the
back Dewey yeah here we go if you're
watching this video Jake Niko friend
Carmichael Nick
Adrian Danny it means I've died or it
also means I may have had a baby and if
I had a baby either way we have to
figure out what to do now that I'm gone
look back so he just fell asleep meaning
I can shoot this video now finally he
eats food stays up for a half hour and
then goes to sleep for half hour and
repeats and so very very difficult to
get anything done such is the
consequence of raising a beautiful child
like this look at us he's got a little
steve ZZ costume on accident like the
life aquatic totally not on purpose
lightning bolts on his fans so we named
him gideon because we thought that was a
cool name actually is this cuz we wanted
to call him little g but now we call me
giddy he looks just like me it's crazy
he's only three weeks old and that means
he only cares about about two or three
things he hears about food or milk for
that matter hears about warmth hears
about sleep or robbery on a 30-minute
schedule every 30 minutes sums up it's a
pretty intense actually the best part
about it
it's that sound thing even myself busy
by playing a lot of these you could also
using this little thing called pocket
operator so it's a tiny little sampler
whenever he makes funny sounds I record
them big beat people on let's start with
template the baby middle this sounds I
love the seriousness of which Sam is
taking three hours this is mixtape
that's my life welcome to it
guys good luck running this video and I
can't wait to see you guys in about a
week or two once this guy learns to
sleep at night it's gonna happen in a
week I mean he could've emailed that to
us
okay you going ready
here we go we broke the record man what
was it 18 are you wiggling so Nick I
think the reason why people are dying in
movies is because they're not using two
hands they just stick to one and they
don't go for the second if you ever get
in this situation any secondary point of
contact with the surface that you're
hanging from or the person you're
hanging or thing you're hanging on to is
going to double or triple the amount of
time you can hold on for subscribe you
know at the end of like movies when like
so he falls off the cliff another person
reaches out with one arm and grabs them
oh yeah I need to do that at the end of
the floors lava video actually it kind
of worked
when did falling a lava and diver there
was that outcome it's charcoal black ice
creams really yeah if you can actually
climb up and save yourself huge dollars
like this I didn't know that was like a
options and save yourself your life dude
I'm some point to go one-handed though
that's the real problem but those of you
who don't know cliff he's really good at
rock climbing also he's the editor next
door at node and he might beat us all
he'll live forever that way this is clip
hanging
don't you die on me sorry for all the
trouble
Oh Sara don't worry about it really
Thanks first time I've ever saved a
man's life
that was a close I can tell my wife I
love myself cliff do you think you stay
with a man's life
I could try friends one wheel wouldn't
turn off me who I thought this side of
about they just kept gone but I had to
bail my bro is here to catch me
[Music]
man I should just stayed away from these
mountains I didn't learn my lesson and
now look the situation I'm in
[Applause]
we learned that all my friends will help
save my life but they'll be unable to if
you're tall you can just do this if you
had the muscles to do it yes this is how
the studio breaks